and video reached out to us and
challenged us to do something cool with
their new mobile workstation laptop so I
reached out to Sam and challenged him to
an art duel he and I are gonna sit down
each one of us with a laptop and see who
can bust up the coolest render but
here's the catch we are going to be on
battery power only so you need to finish
it in the time of one charge of a
battery nothing else no mice no
keyboards the winner of this contest
gets to keep one of these laptops and
the loser has to take the other person's
wallpaper image and make it the
background in their phone for at least
one week all right
Sam's waiting for me let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're on battery power I got an hour
and 15 minutes remaining
94% already oh my gosh as you can see
within our social distancing here not
gonna lie feels pretty risky my wife
Sarah
she advised me not to come today but I
did it anyway just for you guys let's
see what else we got in this asset pack
Beluga Soros we would falling statue I
want to do that this cool freaking robot
here not rigged it's just a collection
of random parts so rigging is when you
have like a skeleton in place and you
can animate something to move a bio
mutant that sounds cool Pizza Steve
hopefully we don't pick Pizza Steve but
the thing is I haven't seen his 3d model
yet and if he's good alright Pizza Steve
let's see what you got
Pizza Steve almost made me lose my mask
Pizza Steve
literally almost filthy he's not rigged
so he's stuck in that pose forever but
why would you ever need to change
anything about Pizza Steve so this is
the sounds what we both have eats of
Steve and we're trying to make them
we're trying to do pizza Steve justice
first thing I got to do is give Pizza
Steve
a makeover this cheese was like too
yellow and I want to get it more of that
like on a nice luscious white and orange
you know and I'm saying like that toasty
toasty oven cheese he needs to have the
meat sweats dripping off them you know
when you pull up a fresh pie out of the
oven that's got the meat sweats I'm at
77% Wow
oh boy my battery 77% that's fast but
it's probably because I've got all this
super high-tech rendering going on right
now
you know it's been really rainy in LA
during the whole pandemic here and it's
really like suited the the mood of the
whole thing
blankets skimpy really kept people
indoors which is a good thing well it's
definitely making my fingers nice and
stiff perfect it is hard to be fast in
the trackpad this trackpad it works
pretty well as long as you make sure you
bind the middle mouse button there's
something because it's a crucial button
for cinema 4d without it you can't move
around in your viewport people taught me
these rendered challenges are all about
figuring out your composition as early
as possible once you know where your
cameras gonna be and your framing you
get to just worry about what you're
gonna see and not what you're not gonna
see I'm gonna call this piece I think
that the toppling of Papa John the fall
of the Papa the fall of the father
I mean Pizza Steve is gonna be a
recurring nightmare for him for the next
year Sam can't replace that picture of
his new baby with a picture of pizza
Steve thrown this man off a pedestal
that's doing the audience the votes for
my piece he wants this videos up it's
too late to vote but if you haven't
followed our Instagram that you go
follow it it's at corridor digital you
know vote on things you can help us know
what you're looking for the quarter
digital Instagram page go follow it I am
at 66% oh man
having this live view or update I really
didn't think that battery Sam what are
you at 68 oh I'm not doing too bad you
know lighting is like what lets you hide
what you are missing the lighting gives
me a mood it gives you shading it gives
you volume without light you don't have
an ocean feel it'll work and in slow if
you like that maybe it's because he got
this matrix glasses on your in bullet
time
this pizzas pies in the oven you can't
take the heat of my pizza oven
fifty-two percent oh Jesus 57 percent
why didn't you tell me that they were
gonna die when we started actually using
the fetus for super intensive rendering
actually designed for creators the
razorblade 15 studio edition was crafted
to unlock workstation class performance
with mobility of one of the most compact
15-inch laptops in the world so I'm
using you know the NVIDIA Quadro r-tx
5000 which is a workstation GPU it has
more memory than gaming GPUs do so for
things like like octane here where
everything's being rendered on the GPU
all your textures need to be stored on
the GPU so this workstation GPU less we
have more higher resolution textures
versus like a gaming GPU remember when I
was telling you about the temperature of
my oven I'm setting the scene for mr.
pizza man's demise this is the : crust
rising 50 percent 44 percent I'm
reaching the end here save as to the
last second the first book Lord even
started working I saved the file and I'm
like this is the file music I got I got
post-processing I got it all enabled and
every freakin spot I possibly can yet
I'm not seeing it I cut my bloom no work
I still not working give any thoughts on
why I suck Oh book though I'm making
valuable time I have to reimpose a scene
they
oh he's full of color and life and this
is looking sick I am quite happy with
this I'm glad I'm glad he feels like
he's a real hotshot today seen that
finish line is the best I'm really like
bust right through it and I guess I
should render it huh
he's doing
[Music]
39% of England final touches for my
lighting
changing settings oops that caustic
valuable time my battery is at 24% 17
minutes left
alright I just wish my Bloom was working
second render here we go
I guess doing this render I can tell you
live about this computer and video also
it has something called video studio
where they basically worked with all
these different companies in the cinema
4d and octane to Adobe to Blackmagic
Design to make sure that their software
is accelerated by these cards that these
cars are being leveraged to their
maximum potential you're leveraging the
power of the card for more than just
playing video games whether you're
encoding video or editing things
engineer or doing effects and After
Effects lots of cool stuff you can do
with a a workstation card like rendering
this really high res render I'm at 52
percent of the way there
renderer version one let's just make a
render just in case my entire world
collapses assuming I didn't screw
anything up I can get it out but if
there's anything screwed up and I'm in
trouble
so I'm getting so close you can paste
this slides this screen up real nice
yeah this is pretty sweet 28 too low for
comfort come on let's go to Gmail come
on phone this is actually okay
concerning why are you so slow right now
I'm gonna stand up so my resolutions
jacked I'll take a photo of the screen
like Clint did I should have used the
mouse let's go Gmail finish that loading
bar a varies at 18 percent 20 percent
remaining 14 percent remaining on the
battery
I am done what do they end up with 18%
not bad
we're gonna text them to each other all
right okay all right I'm ready
are you ready all right ready three two
one cool these are the mutant men went
at Briony hot
he gets sweaty or are they just tears
it's pretty good I'm not gonna lie I
like your environment he made to like
his metal grids and a cool background
your camerawork just makes it wait look
way more intense it's framed really
nicely by my phone Jen did it on a
laptop on battery power the computer
never slowed me down
the only slowness what's in here I
should also mention that if you end up
picking up an RTS studio laptop you get
three months of Adobe for free so access
to all their programs for three months
to learn more about invidious studio and
razor blade studio laptops check out the
links in the top of our description
all right so Sam and I have stayed off
Instagram and so we don't know who the
winner is Christian here has the tally
but before we find out we wanted to hear
from a couple of different professionals
here as their opinion we're joined by
Clint CG master Jake creator of crazy
ideas here at corridor and Griffin who
is our art guy he is the professional
who we must impress the most and the
winner they get the laptop yeah when
they have a Video Creator studio laptops
image 1 all right here we go what
pepperoni hot he gets sweaty this is
tears
the lighting is first thing that I
noticed after the initial obvious stuff
which is I just realized this is an oven
oh I just realized this - no and - Wow
Sam you are a misunderstood artist man
this really speaks to the duality of the
image cuz you know he's standing there
like he's not afraid to die doesn't have
a care
world but behind those sunglasses there
might actually be a whole world with the
pain to me that's art I like that that's
my honest statement my artists statement
I'm also wondering his is crossed hair
or is crossed hat at the end of the day
the things that I appreciate technically
are that the material properties of
everything in the image are consistent
on a technical level the two things that
I have an issue with that haven't been
discussed so far are the sunglasses are
apparently totally opaque and made of a
substance which absorbs all light
because there is absolute perfection and
the leathers in the second half of the
sentence it is legible but I find that
the values between the yellow letters
and the gray pan are a little too close
and they tend to blend I just find that
a little bit distracting but overall I
am very impressed and very saddened by
this piece of grip and I I appreciate
your feedback and honestly next time
I'll I'll try and incorporate some of
these ideas and with that we have render
to
[Music]
this is an eco s sign he's got a lot of
yeah this is an eco vendor for sure are
they jumping out room are they tossing
him into hell it's hard to tell
this piece is titled the rising crusts
and it's about pizza the common man
rising to the top overthrowing Papa John
I think composition is great I think the
Lighting's great your message is that
this is the pizza crust the rising crust
it leaves me wondering who the real
tyrant is when when one man with an army
of pepperoni monster zombies topples
another man I'm wondering who the pizza
king is really the difference between
materials is a little bit more
noticeable on this even in the the pizza
man he appears to have a little bit less
intravenous to him but overall I do
think the composition is very nice it's
a very kind of classical composition the
light leads you through the page and
allows you to explore with your eyes I'm
a big fan of how much full frontal
nudity there is in this image that's
that's working really strongly here I'll
take that to heart
all righty why don't Clint Griffin and
Jake provide their personal votes on
what their favorite render was I gotta
go with Niko's if I had to pick a
background for my phone for a week it'd
be Niko's Sam's makes me feel something
and believe in something and forgiving
faith giving me that that glimmer of
hope in this trying time my vote goes to
Sam all righty well the votes are in and
adding those votes to the Instagram
contest we've been running the winner is
render to Niko's fall rising crust
rising crust thank you thank you
everybody thank you to the voters I give
you guys thank you to pizza pepperoni in
particular I just want to thank all the
pepperoni pizzas out there can't wait to
make some more sick renders well Sam
you're gonna have to uh you're gonna
have to die on this on your phone that
was a wonderful render challenge
and I'm happy to post this beautiful
image let's see it there yeah wow that
looks pretty good
phone background yeah enjoy that laptop
Nico yeah that laptop Nico you know you
guys I did some heavy thinking I'm gonna
donate that laptop to court or digital
because corridor digital is much more
need of a workstation laptop and I'm
using right now that's right any time
you want it belongs to all of us yeah
thanks for watching everybody and falsi
at corridor digital on instagram he
won't miss on the next one if you're
following us now I'll see I'm gonna go
in the hyperspace see y'all later
good drive out of here bye